we are recreating a tremendous video
from Reddit a few years ago of iron
filings flying up in the air visualizing
a magnetic field around a magnet ready
yep
oh yeah you can clearly see it there see
the curves the way it's coming in in
like two circles from above and below
and sometimes it spins around to the
other side almost so if you get a piece
that's sort of on the outer orbit of the
Ring it will come around straight into
the middle there must be a cut-off point
where the weight of the iron filing is
falling comes around and spins around
all the way it must be like two inches
maybe look there's a piece here that
goes
way around and then it swings around to
the opposite side I like the
acceleration of some of the bigger
chunks of it as well a lot of
information there you can kind of see
the the entire range
pretty far out and I mean far out it's
pretty fun also it's pretty far out